what a lovely welcome good evening
ladies and gentlemen it's great to see
so many of you here it's fantastic James
Comey the former director of the FBI who
served under presidents Bush Obama and
Trump opens his book cover with a
question what is ethical leadership how
do you do
what is right instead of what is
politically expedient now he tries to
answer that and explain the actions that
turned out to be so pivotal to America's
2016 presidential election the election
of Donald Trump in the following 300
pages of his book a higher loyalty and
tonight we have the chance to talk to
him about the decisions he made the
calls he took the people he met the
conversations that took place behind
closed doors
the lives that were perhaps changed
forever
by that curious set of circumstances
that have been played and replayed in so
many of our minds and I'm sure in James
Comey zoned director Comey and I met
once before it was shortly after
publication of his book in New York when
I interviewed him for BBC Newsnight but
things have moved on since then both in
terms of America's own story
the president's newest moves and
policies and in terms of what we also
know about the Department of Justice
report in to your own actions you were
called insubordinate we'll come back to
that in a second let's start with a nice
gentle one James Comey thank you thank
you do you feel responsible for bringing
Donald Trump to power
okay
that's all you got huh that's it I I
don't although I hear people who make
the argument that the decisions we at
the FBI and I ultimately made in October
had an influence on the election I don't
know whether that's true I hope and pray
it's not true I hope it doesn't sound
odd to you it just increases the pain it
doesn't change how I think about the
decision that had to be made on October
28th because we couldn't make that
decision thinking about whose electoral
fortunes it would be helped or hurt and
and so it doesn't change how I think
about it believe it or not I hope some
day my wife is actually here tonight was
a strong Hillary Clinton supporter and
she would like there to be a she would
like you to be a scientific study that
proves her husband was utterly
irrelevant and I think that would be a
wonderful thing but honestly it doesn't
change looking backwards how I think
about the terrible choices I faced until
that scientific experiment is done do
you accept that arguably after Putin
perhaps no one had greater outside
influence on that election than you
I actually don't and here's why that
that's a little bit like let's assume
that my decision had an impact on the
election it's a little bit like blaming
the a kicker in American football for
missing a field goal at the last second
of a game that you were supposed to win
by 40 points that that you could go back
and say well okay well why did you have
why did you talk about classified
information on your server why did you
not campaign in Michigan and Wisconsin
and western Pennsylvania there's lots of
questions to be asked as to why the
election was that close that there could
be a marginal influence by a decision
but I try to stay away I just I just
voiced a lot of the analysis I've heard
I try and stay away from it because I
knew when we made the decision the
reason we hated the decision was there
was a chance we
have an impact on the election the
question was which of the two options
was the least terrible but I assumed we
might have an impact and so that's how I
think about it I don't know that I would
ascribe that kind of responsibility to
myself especially I look back over the
significant events of the two years
before that and so I'm not trying to
dodge responsibility but I'm not trying
to yank it and hug it to myself either
let us go back let's start as it were
give you a bit more of the story before
we get to the end if I start you in July
2015
Hillary Clinton's the Democratic front
runner you open that first investigation
into Clinton and her personal email
account and it's worth explaining
because I think this is something that
people often get wrong it wasn't that
she wrote on Gmail exactly it was the
question of whether classified
information had been passed through an
unclassified source exactly something
gets lost all the time it doesn't matter
how she's communicating so long as she's
not communicating classified information
on a system that's not supposed to
contain that kind of information and you
were trying to work out whether
classified information had gone out of
the system and what she was thinking if
that had been the case that was the
investigation essentially correct
because we knew from long work with the
counterespionage section of the
Department of Justice which is the part
of the department would handle the into
the prosecution that without proof that
the government employee knew they were
doing something they shouldn't be doing
they would never prosecute it they
didn't prosecute mistakes or sloppiness
even extraordinary sloppiness you had to
prove the person knew they were
communicating in a way that was
prohibited within with classified
information and that that's as it should
be the rest was left for Discipline you
get fired you get fine you get suspended
but not prosecuted unless we could show
that that mental intention to do
something wrong so it is a criminal
investigation that's opened and you talk
about the background noise the drumbeat
of the conservative media I think is
your phrase the sense that it was
unlikely to be a case that the
Department of Justice would prosecute
you knew that
and yet you went ahead and you made that
public now for many people that will
have been the moment where your role
changed you crossed the line you said
I'm gonna go out there and I'm gonna
tell the public exactly what I'm doing
and you knew what the ramifications of
that would be yes I got to back you up
just a little bit we got that case
referred to us publicly by one of the
institutional watchdogs in the United
States the intelligence community
Inspector General they had done a review
and saw lots of classified topics in her
unclassified email system and so they
sent it to the FBI as a referral career
people in the FBI opened it to
investigate because it was worthy of
investigation we knew that unless we
found something really interesting it
probably wasn't gonna be something that
would be prosecuted after ten months of
investigation that seemed clearer and
clearer to me and then the challenge was
so how does the Obama Justice Department
credibly close a criminal investigation
of one of the two candidates for
President of the United States and not
just any candidate but the Democratic
candidate who had been Secretary of
State under President Obama how do you
do that in a way that maintains the
American people's trust and confidence
in the institutions of Justice you're
leaping your head no no I'm trying to
say what I yeah you just opened the
first one you've opened this understood
you talked about the announcement at the
end no I want to talk first of all about
the July 2015 where you've opened it and
you've made that public no we didn't
make it public until three months later
three months later so you're into the
investigation and I think this is what
you're referring to and he said either
way it was going to play badly you just
had to side which was worse than it was
your was it your deputy director
Giuliani who said Giuliano I should say
very different years very different
characters I must close with the second
one anymore
welcome onto him a bit later he said and
I quote you know you're totally screwed
right yeah so that sense that you and he
both knew or both believed whatever
course of action you did at that point
will be the end right to take a current
sports metaphor at that moment we were
appointed the referee in a World Cup
match that was going to be vicious and
incredibly close down to the wire so
there was a really good chance one team
was gonna hate us now it turned out that
both teams hated us well played but we
knew at that moment we're stuck in the
middle of this game the whole world is
watching no matter what we do one half
the political spectrum will be angry we
could recommend charges that would anger
the Democrats we could refuse to
recommend charges I would anger the
Republicans there's certain freedom in
that by the way but what was interesting
this you took it to the Attorney General
Loretta Lynch and she advised you not to
call it an investigation she took you
aside and she said don't call it an
investigation call it a matter yeah what
did you sense she was trying to tell you
in that what was that about I don't know
for sure this was three months after we
had started the investigation and our
normal practice at the Department of
Justice and the FBI is we don't confirm
the existence of an investigation unless
it's in the public interest to do so
and so typically we would confirm an
investigation to reassure the public
that we're looking at something that
they care about or to explain activity
that would otherwise be evident and so
after three months of refusing to
confirm an investigation that the whole
world knew we were doing because we were
out interviewing people and the
candidates were talking about it I asked
to meet with the Attorney General
because I was about to have a encounter
with the press where I knew I'd be asked
again and I said to Loretta who I like
and like then and still like I said I
think it's probably time for us to
confirm that we're doing this and she
said I agree but call it a matter and I
said why would I do that and she said
just call it a matter and that actually
made the hair stand up on the back of my
neck a little because
the Clinton campaign had been struggling
to avoid characterization of this as an
investigation they'd called it a
security referral a security review and
so Loretta's direction to me we don't do
matters we do investigations it's in our
name and that that direction that that
direction to me roughly tracked what the
political people were doing and so I was
that's what made the hair stand up I
probably should have said Loretta come
on
can I just interpret those the hairs
standing up yeah
means that you felt she was acting on
what Hillary Clinton would have
preferred right now whether that was her
intention or not I didn't know but it
was it was eerily tracking the political
effort to minimize the work do you think
that was her phrase matter or do you
think somebody had asked her to pass
that on to you I don't know I don't know
and look it's possible that for some
reason unconnected to the political
narrative she wanted me to lower the
temperature on it but it was close
enough in time and in language to the
political effort to minimize that it
concerned me which is why I asked her
directly she's new and so I asked her
directly why would I do that and she
just gave me the order again which to my
mind said the boss doesn't want to talk
about this anymore but she's your boss
so you do it correct and also thought
it's kind of silly because the press as
much as I love the press they're gonna
miss the distinction if I say we're
invested we're looking at that matter
they're all gonna report I confirm the
investigation I'm widget which is what
happened yeah so this investigation gets
underway you find so far nothing of
substance and you're trying to close it
in a way that still maintains confidence
and Trust and what you do and for the
American people at a time of sort of
heightened political activity and then
in early 2016 there was a development
and you say this was a development that
threatened to challenge that effort
significantly a development still
unknown to the American public to this
day materials from
classified source that could have cast
doubt on the Attorney General's
independence with a Clinton
investigation yeah so what could have
killed that confidence and Trust
I have to choose my words carefully
because it's still classified the FBI
reviewed my book and approved me using
precisely that language so I'm not going
to be too expansive here there was
material that was shared with the US
government that I didn't believe was
very it was real and that would be used
by partisans to argue if it became
public that Loretta Lynch was in cahoots
with the Clinton campaign a source of
dossier OCAD I don't want to
characterize it but it was it was
documents that would allow people to
argue that now I didn't believe that
because actually my only conversation
with Loretta about the case had been
that matter won and then as far as I
could tell she didn't touch it again I
also knew her and respected her but I
mentioned this a couple times already
faith and confidence in the perception
of Justice is important is as important
as the reality of justice and so I
started to worry hm
this actually could be used by people to
argue that the Obama Justice Department
is faintly compromised and is working on
behalf of the Clinton campaign I don't
want to get you into trouble and now
you're sort of hands are tied but I'm
just I'm trying to if you like explain
it for it for a British audience what it
could have be whether you think it was
about her being offered a job as an
attorney general under Clinton wouldn't
have been in relation to her career path
would have been in relation to Bill
Clinton because he described this very
odd meeting of the two of them on a
private jet and a 20-minute conversation
nobody else heard was a personal matter
was it a career matter it reflected
again I'm not crediting it although the
the material is real some people have
said it was a forgery no real
information that I didn't believe but
that that would they're related to her
discharge of her official duties in
connection with the investigation
and would open her up and all of us
the accusation that she was controlling
the FBI for the benefit of the Clinton
campaign and keeping them informed on
what I was doing and the challenge was
and the hard thing about talking about
is not just the classification is I
don't wanna hurt Loretta but this was
real and a fine you about it to cheek
she she didn't know about at the time we
defensively briefed her told her about
it later on but it was concerning enough
that you actually see echoes of it in
I'll give you a little bit of thing that
the American press hasn't figured out
yet you actually see echoes of it in the
public text of Peter struck and Lisa
Paige the two people who are writing on
it there's a point in the early part of
2007 16 were they react to new
information and start saying the
director is now going to have to call
for a special prosecutor that's what
they were reacting to but it wasn't
those lines just to bring you up to date
with the unfamiliar names perhaps that
the lines that they said will stop Trump
we're gonna stop Trump no I think I
don't know when that was but these were
tell to make sure the folks know this
sort of tale these were to a senior
agent on the case and a junior lawyer
each of whom were married to other
people had a romantic relationship and
to hide it from their spouses they used
our phones to text with each other
and I know this this may lead you to
believe we don't have the brightest
bulbs at the FBI but surely they would
know we archive all of our texts at the
FBI and so in these texts they're
carrying on an affair and they're
bad-mouthing everybody everybody and but
they especially badmouth Donald Trump
and so we'll probably get to that later
but they react to this information that
I'm talking about in those texts they
don't disclose it in their text but they
were and everybody on the team was very
worried about this information now what
consoled us was this isn't gonna become
public until after I'm dead right this
is so sensitive that'll be 50 years
before the United States government
Declassified it and so I thought you
know it's a little worrisome and there
were other things that had happened
President Obama had twice given press
interviews where he said there's really
no case there with Hillary Clinton which
he didn't know but I thought well this
isn't gonna come out and so fifty years
from now people may say ah looking back
I wonder if there was an issue with the
Attorney General just go back on that
cuz it's really interesting President
Obama went on TV he went on 60 minutes
and he said Clinton's email use was a
mistake now you think he actually
jeopardized your whole investigations
credibility by saying that sure
I mean we're now in an entirely
different world but at least then I was
shocked that the President of the United
States
and was that something you would would
you feel able to say that privately to
him why did you do that that was an
incredibly unhelpful thing I don't know
again I didn't have one-on-one meetings
with the president I'd say it's back in
the good old days yeah and so I I don't
know but I was really surprised by that
and troubled he's a highly intelligent
and principled person and so I don't
know why he did it but again the central
challenge is gonna be closing this case
credibly with the American people the
Obama Justice Department convincing the
American people we did a credible
investigation the President of the
United States saying publicly there's no
there they're severely undercut that so
that was another brick in the load for
my worry that we're gonna struggle to
credibly end this thing so you're about
to bring it to a close now we're on July
the 15th 2016 and it's the end of the
first investigation and you're writing
drafts and you're trying to work out the
right phrases you you should you say she
was sloppy should you say she was
grossly negligent should he say she was
careless in the end you give that press
conference the first time I think you
became a recognizable public figure on
the sort of world stage and you called
Hillary Clinton a non criminal but
extremely careless it was a choice of
words that you came to regret yeah
because my goal was to be transparent
with the American people and by
transparency describe what we found what
we make of it and what we're
recommending I wasn't trying to attack
her but I figured I've got to
characterize it in some way but I
screwed up the characterization because
I don't get to boring to lawyers here
but that allowed people in Congress
Republicans to seize on an old statute
from 1917 that made gross negligence
crime and say hi he says she committed
gross negligence look at extremely
careless they're the same thing what I
was trying to do was say okay there's
ordinary sloppiness where you leave a
document in a Starbucks and then there's
criminal conduct where you know you're
doing stuff you shouldn't do and then
there's this which actually is quite a
bit above the Starbucks it doesn't quite
get here
I should have said actually really
sloppy to characterize it in a way that
people could understand but by choosing
extremely careless I walked into this
whole sideshow about this old statute
you had at that point done something
which broke with protocol you knew that
you said you were personally offering
the American people unusual transparency
so just the the fact that the FBI
director was going out making this
speech choosing his words carefully
you're already again cross that line
you'd sort of entered into the public
dare I say political sphere at that
point I get why you say that I actually
think about it differently I entered
into the public sphere to offer the
American people transparency so they
would believe their institutions of
justice had acted honestly competently
and independently we were investigating
one of the two candidates for President
of the United States the Attorney
General had a variety of things that
made it difficult for her to announce it
if we've done the normal thing and just
said one-line no case here a corrosive
doubt not driven by Fox News or
political wing nuts but by ordinary
Americans about William what's the deal
here
would have crept in and undercut the
credibility of really important
institutions and I had the ability to do
something the department justice has
long done in extraordinary cases where
the public has great interest
we've long given them lots of details
about cases that we didn't charge so
they knew we did it in a good way
Ferguson Missouri is an example with a
terrible killing of Michael Brown by a
police officer in Ferguson Missouri the
FBI investigated that we brought no
charges against the police officer but
we published an 80 some page report on
the entire investigation because the
people deserved that transparency so my
thinking here was we are never gonna get
out of this incredibly without
transparency what I did that broken norm
was I stepped away from the Attorney
General to offer that transparency I
stepped away from my boss and I I was
doing that on purpose and I knew I would
get enormous heat for it so the story
ends there yes we're done
except of course it doesn't because 12
days before the election itself you
reopen that investigation after your
teen found hundreds of thousands of
emails on the laptop of Anthony Weiner
the ex-husband of Clinton's aged Huma
Abedin so that is the moment which
presumably you have played over and over
in your head and many of us here in the
audience will have done the same why did
you go public why did you open it then
why didn't you wait there would be a
totally coherent rational position to
say you know what this may have to be
done but I just need more time I'm not
gonna say anything now yeah the biggest
nightmare of my professional life
hardest decision I've ever been part of
I'm sitting there 11th this 12 days
before the election when we started
debating what to do and I've been told
we need to reopen this investigation
because we've found hundreds of
thousands of her emails remember we only
found an entire universe of 30,000
originally she turned over 30,000 to the
Department of State and she deleted
another 30,000 this is hundreds of
thousands of her emails and something
much more important than that we never
found any emails from her first three
months as Secretary of State because
then she was using a blackberry a
personal blackberry account and we never
found any remember we opened by talking
about the importance of intent if there
was going to be evidence that Hillary
Clinton knew she was doing something
with classified information she
shouldn't do it would likely be then
when somebody emailed her back saying
hey boss you can't talk about this kind
of stuff on unclassified system so I'm
sitting there with the investigative
team they said boss there are hundreds
of thousands of emails and we think we
may have found the missing emails this
could change the result and the
Department of Justice this is something
people overlook the Obama Department of
Justice believes we have to get a search
warrant so everybody agreed with that we
need to reopen so what do I do I have
told Congress and so has the Attorney
General repeatedly under oath in the
summer and the American people were done
here there's no case here and the
Republicans screamed that we were
corrupt and we fought back and said no
no
there's nothing here this is done the
American people can rely on it now it's
October 27th and that's not true anymore
in a huge way and the whole thing may
change oh my god the norm that I've
lived my entire career by the no rules
about this but a norm is if you can
avoid action and then run up to an
election you avoid action that might
have any impact on the election my
problem was I'm sitting there twelve
days before the election and I can only
see two actions I can speak or I can
conceal if I speak that'll be really bad
it's 12 days before an election oh my
god what about the other one if I can
seal from the American people in
Congress that they're relying on a lie I
believe I'll destroy the FBI for the
rest of my natural life forget about me
the institution will be destroyed
I cannot conceal and so there's only
tight no one's ever come up with another
choice for me speak or be silent speak
or conceal and everybody might reach a
different conclusion
but you stare at that on October 28th
and tell me that's not the hardest
decision you've seen and we debated and
debated and debated and I asked my staff
tell the Attorney General I think I have
to tell Congress and word came back
saying she thinks that's a bad idea but
she doesn't want to speak to you about
it
except this is where you appear guilty
of double standards because you knew the
FBI knew there was a concurrent FBI
investigation into the alleged links
between Trump's team and Russia you knew
that but you decided not to share that
with the public so the thing that is
really hard to understand is faced with
this awful speak conceal speak conceal
everyone's on your side but then you
throw in the fact that there was this
other investigation into the other side
and you did conceal that yeah I get why
people say that but you have to stare at
the facts to see how very very different
the situations are the Hillary Clinton
investigation began with a public
referral we wouldn't talk about it for
three months even though it had begun
with a public referral a public document
sent to us three months later we said
were doing this work and we wouldn't
talk about it again until we finished it
and she was the target of that
investigation it was about her and we
finished the investigation the Russia
counterintelligence investigation was
not focused on Donald Trump we opened it
in late July to try and figure out are
any Americans working with the Russians
on this massive effort that we see going
on with the Russians but wouldn't that
have been worth telling them well I
guess I'd have to ask me what what do
you imagine me saying to the American
people American people want you to know
this we've just opened an investigation
we don't know where there's anything to
it it doesn't involve Donald Trump but
involve some people who are peripheral
to his campaign not key people but we
don't know his anything there but we
thought you ought to know that but
that's kind of the same as the Weiner
emails isn't it you know he wasn't part
of that you found emails that you didn't
yet know would lead directly it very
nicely okay i but I see it very very
differently because we've already spoken
about the closure of that investigation
which is what puts us on the horns of
that dilemma speak or conceal and so I
see it as very very different it was
actually so obvious to everyone involved
that our norms did not justify any talk
about a brand new counterintelligence
investigation that it never came up I
don't remember anybody raising should we
talk about this what we wrestled with
what
President Obama wrestled with was should
we tell the American people about what
the Russians are doing and not whether
we're trying to figure out where their
Americans are part of it what should we
tell them about this big effort that we
just figured out in actually we've
figured it out starting in the middle of
June when they start to release stolen
documents they come back to something we
talked about earlier it was then that I
conclude remember I said that the
classified stuff will come out after I'm
dead no no no in the middle of June all
of a sudden it dawned on me that stuff
about Loretta Lynch that's coming now
this was when the the Russian hacked
email started appearing that's the
beginning of the that's coming now
another reason I thought I love Loretta
I got to get away from her to announce
this result then come forward to the
summertime what do we say about the
broader investigation I actually offered
to be the voice of inoculation to the
American people I wrote an op-ed that we
were going to send to the New York Times
where I said hey American people the
Russians are coming for our election
they're trying to interfere with it
it's a massive effort cyber and all
kinds of other things and the
administration didn't take me up on it
President Obama wrestled with it all the
way until October wasn't there a problem
though that you felt she was always
gonna win but somewhere you'd made a
calculation that you had to keep her
presidency clean that you know once
again the drum pee that the conservative
media was ringing in your ears and you
didn't shut out the polls or the press
or the pundits and you thought well
she's gonna be President you made that
assumption didn't you not consciously I
didn't I really worked hard to keep out
of my conscious deliberations any
consideration of the polls or politics
in my book I guess I've made a mistake
for a Washington related book I try to
be introspective and so I asked myself
that question the whole world thought
she was gonna be President could that
have influenced my decision and they
understand sir has to be of course it
could influence my decision I actually
don't think it changes the decision it
just made it easier in a way if Donald
Trump were up by 20 points in the polls
I still can't conceal that because it
will still destroy the FBI but if
Hillary Clinton is going to be the next
president
it's easy to avoid concealing because
you will her her presidency will be
doomed from the moment she takes office
because the FBI covered up for her to
allow her to get elected as you know
Hillary Clinton believes that ultimately
cost her the election when we spoke in
April I asked you if you'd talk to her
about this at all
presumably you still haven't no I
haven't I don't know her I've never
spoken to her at all that's odd
there's been no private communication no
no communication at all between the two
of you I don't I don't think it's odd I
think we'll be out if I reached out to
her that maybe I don't mean that
facetiously I look that that she's a
person for reasons that I totally
understand is in a lot of pain I
understand why she focuses on me at
least in part for the source of that
pain that makes me feel bad I can't help
that I have nothing against her I wasn't
trying to hurt her I've read her that
chapter of her book where she talks
about she thinks I shift her with a
prison homemade knife kind of thing and
if I talked to her I would say I'm not
trying to plug my book to you Secretary
Clinton I'm sure she's got numerous
copies well if she could just read those
two chapters of the book she won't agree
with me maybe she won't but she can't
walk away thinking that I shift her that
I was trying to help elect Donald Trump
president and because it's just not true
and it's any of that kind that would
actually be gratifying if she could take
that away we're gonna move on to Donald
Trump in a moment so before I do just
before we do though the Department of
Justice report came out last week it
called you insubordinate not politically
biased but insubordinate um I wonder if
you think that you have permanently
damaged the institution of the FBI and
what you did I certainly don't think
permanently damaged I think the
decisions I had to make damage first of
all they did a lot of damage to me and
my reputation but they they did damage
the institution but compared to what
I had choices to make between bad and
worse and I know it's hard to live
imaginary lives but I think if I had
chosen to let Loretta Lynch announced
the closing of it and most importantly
if I had concealed in October the
Inspector General will be writing a
report about how I destroyed the
institutions
do you accept insubordinate as a finding
I kind of do
and I didn't at first I had an emotional
reaction when I saw that I said that's
nonsense
she dumped it on me Loretta Lynch at the
end of June after she met privately with
with Bill Clinton on an airplane and the
world blew up in the United States
without consulting with me announced
publicly I'm not going to step out of
this investigation but I will accept Jim
Comey's recommendation and that of the
career prosecutors and so the notion
that I was insubordinate by taking that
that was handed to me and announcing my
recommendation and my initial reaction
was that can't be right
it's actually fair because of this way I
intentionally did not tell her what I
was going to say and I'm her subordinate
she would normally expect that I would
tell her what I was going to say so in
that sense I was insubordinate and
that's a painful thing for a career
person like me to absorb I still believe
it was the right thing to do I think the
criticism is fair but I think it was the
right thing to do I'm gonna fast forward
now to January 2017 you're on your way
to Trump Tower you're going to tell
president-elect Trump about a secret
dossier we know it as the Christopher
steel dossier allegations of misconduct
conspiracy between Trump's campaign team
and the Russian government and this is
taking place in New York in Trump Tower
and I think what you described is a sort
of gold curtain room what's going
through your head there were two parts
to this briefing and it was ordered by
President Obama after the election he
directed the FBI the CIA the NSA under
the leadership of the Director of
National Intelligence to pull together
all the American government's
intelligence on what the Russians did
and how we know it and so that effort
lasted about a month
and in early January President Obama's
deadline he was briefed on it in the
Oval Office and then the leaders of
Congress were briefed and then we flew
to New York to meet the incoming
president and his team and so there were
two parts to the briefing the first was
the Director of National Intelligence
was telling the president-elect about
the findings of this entire report and
that I was not nervous about that part
of the briefing the next part was the
part that gave me a pain in my stomach
was that I had drawn the assignment to
stay behind a meet alone with the
president-elect to brief him on a
portion of the material from what's now
known as the steel dossier that made
salacious allegations about his
engagement with prostitutes in Moscow
during a visit to the Miss Universe
pageant in 2013 and the intelligence
community thought and and cleared this
with this is the one that the American
press even mr. Lee call pp gate right
here it's about the prostitutes being
ordered by President Trump to pee piss
on the bed in which the Obamas once
stayed in a Moscow hotel right is that
words that have never left my lips not
to him you didn't actually say that to
him right no I and that I don't like to
say any of it but but my assignment was
and President Obama was told this is the
way we're gonna approach it that because
I was staying and that the CIA leader
was leading the Director of National
Intelligence was leaving and the FBI has
counterintelligence responsibilities we
couldn't keep this secret from the
president-elect we thought it was about
to become public so we'd only keep
secrets from the new president and one
of the ways if there's anything to it
and we didn't know where was anything to
it but if it's anything to it one of the
ways the FBI defeats efforts to
blackmail is we go to the person who
might be blackmail and said hey we want
you to know we know about this did you
believe any of it I didn't believe it
actually when I first saw it I didn't
believe it at all and that my view
changed a little bit on that
how much of it do you believe now know
the things I never this I will actually
say I think it's possible that it's true
oh well all of it's a hard thing I mean
the whole salacious stuff then yeah the
incident at the Miss Universe I think
it's possible it's true now I can't
assign up a percentage to the
probability but it's it's nonzero and I
say that I you know I'm I know it's
funny but I'm not saying it to be funny
it's just based on my encounters with
the president after he became president
that his is constantly bringing it up in
order to deny it so he knew all this he
knew what you were going to tell I don't
know no I don't know that and so the
plan was I will stay behind to meet with
the president-elect alone to tell him
this as my first meeting with him and
and so that was the part I was I'm not
sure how much I was paying attention to
the first meeting because the second
meeting was gonna be very difficult and
so we did that I met along with him and
it was such a stressful thing for me I
actually remember looking down on myself
from the ceiling like an out-of-body
experience I'm talking to the
president-elect about prostitutes how
did I end up here and and so but I don't
know not his reaction did not tell me
one way or another whether he knew what
I was going to say but I didn't go into
the some of the details you went into I
wanted to put him on notice so I just
talked about prostitutes in Moscow Ritz
I think I said Ritz Carlton Miss
Universe pageant if that doesn't do it I
don't need to go any further and so that
that's what I told him about this was
one of the first of many Cajuns that you
found yourself alone with him you
described a dinner as sort of an early
dinner that he's booked with you and he
demands your loyalty and all the hairs
on your neck going up again at that
point yeah and it surprised me that all
I could think of in the moment was don't
move
don't blink don't don't twitch
so I just stared at him and if I'd been
more prepared for that I might've had
something better to do but I just stared
but why wasn't your response to say mr.
president that's not my job
yeah that's what I meant by the better
to do was that going through your head
at all did he think I have to shut this
down and explain to him what my role is
right now shut this down
is difficult with any president again
you're alone with the president United
States just taken office so I don't be
too hard on myself it would take someone
unusual in that moment to say mr.
president me tell you what's supposed to
work and especially with this president
given his style of interaction it's just
waves of words to get something in you
have to adapt on sort of auditioning me
for your own job right do you still want
it are you gonna stay on would you like
to carry on you're right I'm ready
that's right before the loyalty request
that's when I started to get a weird
feeling because he had already several
times told me he hoped I was staying and
now he was talking like I needed to ask
for my job and so that was odd and then
he directly asked for my loyalty and
again all I could think of in the moment
was don't respond just stare at him he
then broke we stared each other for a
couple seconds which is a long time
alone with the president when he just
asked you a question and then he looked
down at his salad and we continued on
but I got better because then I used
other opportunities during the
conversation to interrupt which you have
to do to interrupt to stress the
importance of the independence the
distance why it matters so much why it's
a paradox I said to him so many
presidents think they have to pull the
justice institutions close because
trouble comes from there and it makes
things worse we have to be at a distance
and so by the time he came back around
to asking me again for loyalty I had
been able to get this in the things that
if I'd had the presence of mind to do I
would have front-loaded but I got it in
but you've started writing memos at this
point now I'm curious because the memos
are notes that you know you need to make
to record these conversations did you
imagine you must have imagined that they
would one day
we made public point no I didn't
actually I thought it's possible but
that I needed them in the event there
was ever a dispute about these
conversations to protect the FBI and to
protect myself because we were talking
about things that touched on him
personally and that affected the core of
the FBI's responsibilities and me
personally and honestly that he might
lie about it and so I never did that
with President Obama I never didn't with
President Bush but I thought I have to
have a contemporaneous record God
willing I'll never need it but if
there's a circumstance where it becomes
germane and the president's gonna lie
about it
I need a record right and it hits a
height when he asks you to drop the
investigation into his security advisor
Michael Flynn might flown over Russian
connections you are sure he said that to
you there is no question in your mind
that he asks you to drop that
investigation because he denies it of
course yes I'm aware of that
I am I am absolutely certain and here's
how you know how certain I am I testify
not only did I write a memo about it
right afterwards I testified under oath
about that conversation in front of the
United States Senate last June when I
thought there were tapes I thought as
president Trump tweeted at me that I
better hope there aren't tapes of our
conversations I went and testified it on
about it under oath believing there
might be an audio tape from the Oval
Office
because I know what that audio tape
would say so just back to that meeting
he's told you to drop the investigation
who do you tell who do you trust in the
White House who do you look to as your
sort of mature States men and women to
go to in the White House there was
nobody to go to I went back and met with
the leadership team at the FBI General
Counsel my chief of staff the deputy
director I think there was no one there
was no one who reported to trump who
advised him in his close circle that you
felt you could say this is this is
getting dangerous no I had tried to have
a conversation like that with his chief
of staff a week before you're talking
about a meeting happened on Valentine's
Day February 14th
week before that I'd gone there to speak
to the president's chief of staff and
one of the things we talked about was
the importance of communications with
the FBI by the White House going through
regular channels and I laid out how it
was supposed to work at the end of that
meeting he said hey do you want to see
the president okay so we're now in May
of 2017 you've had the chicken supper
and a few of these meetings and the Mike
Flynn thing and chicken parmesan chicken
parmesan the prawn salad
I remember the many and you are not in
Washington I think you're in Arizona or
you and you hear the news when I get
fired that you've been fired I'm in Los
Angeles speaking to employees and I see
it on TVs at the back of the room
actually at first it said Comey resigns
and I knew that wasn't true and so I
thought it was a prank I turned to my
staff you probably believe this but the
FBI is a hilarious place my staff was
over here to my right and I turned to
them and said that took a lot of work
and then I went back talking to the
employees and then it changed and said
Comey fired and I thought okay they're
not that's not them and that's how I
found out without you being fired there
would be no Muller investigation
presumably Steve Bannon called the
firing of Jim Comey the worst political
mistake in modern history what he meant
was that you weren't about to hold back
the gloves were off and everyone would
get to know everything do you sense that
if you hadn't been fired we wouldn't be
having the Muller investigation I don't
know we might have that because the
Department of Justice was still trying
to sort out how they were going to
supervise that investigation because the
Attorney General was about to recuse
himself step away from anything related
to Russia and I knew that was coming
which is why I couldn't go to him to
tell him about this and the incoming
number two had promised during his
confirmation hearings that he would look
at the question of whether they should
appoint a special prosecutor
to handle this so it's possible that
even if I hadn't been fired there would
still be a special prosecutor I think
would hasten the appointment of the
special prosecutor is that I caused the
world to know about Donald Trump's
request on Valentine's Day that I
dropped the investigation and do you
think and I put tremendous pressure on
the Department of Justice is your sense
at this point going back to the other
Giuliani the one you're not so fond of
that we will see a closure to the mole
investigation that is satisfactory
depends of what your definition of
satisfactory is do you think well but
Muller will be allowed to finish his job
I do I think despite the noise that it's
likely you know you never want to say
for certain with our president but it's
likely that he's figured out that not
only would it be politically disastrous
to fire Muller it would be ineffective
because the Department of Justice is
almost entirely made up of career people
somebody else would pick up if not the
whole thing pieces of the investigation
and you can only fix it by firing
everyone in the FBI or the Department of
Justice
Deaton that can't happen do you think
the Muller investigation will ultimately
find there were connections between
Trump himself and Russia I don't know
what is your gut feeling I don't have a
gut feeling because I don't know what
he's developed since I left I can only
say one thing with certainty well two
things everything you've read in the
media about Bob Mahler's investigation
is uninformed because there been no
leaks from Bob Miller's operation and so
we none of us Gooding may have any idea
what he knows we've seen the charges
against 19 different people which shows
he's working very quickly but I don't
know where he'll end up except my second
certainty is if he's left to do his job
he will find the collection of facts
that allows us to see what the truth is
and I hope Democrats aren't I know they
are but they shouldn't be rooting for a
particular outcome Republicans shouldn't
be we should be rooting for the truth if
Bob Muller can do his job we will be
able to see the truth and I don't know
what it'll be I really don't it's
entirely possible he will find
there is not credible evidence that
President Trump either participated or
knew about conspiracy with the Russians
in connection with their election
interference it's possible he'll
conclude Donald Trump did not have the
requisite state of mind under American
law to obstruct justice even when he I
didn't mean that as a shot at him but I
see what you're doing I want to open it
up to questions in a second just before
I do because we're right on the cusp of
an extraordinary moment in Trump's own
political fortunes dare I say in the
heartbeat of America right now
we saw the President Roh back on the
child separation immigration policy last
night a sign presumably that he saw how
damaging that had been a question from
somebody earlier via Twitter asked me to
put to you are American children safer
in schools or cages which probably gives
you a sense of how that whole thing was
received here and the questions that the
world has about it what are your
thoughts on that it was horrible
immoral conduct that may serve as an
inflection point for America the
challenge in America is we go through
these our line is always upward sloping
but it's a jagged line we make progress
we retrenched you react we make progress
we were chance to react and the turning
point between the ending of a
retrenchment and more progress is often
what I call the awakening of the Giant
the American people are a bell-curve
at the wings our wing nuts from the far
left and the far right they're
passionate they follow politics all of
that at the middle is the sleeping giant
it's the embodiment of the values of the
American people they're not following
politics they're raising their kids
every so often in American history they
awaken they awakened when dogs bit
children in Birmingham Alabama and
children were killed with bombs in
Birmingham Alabama in 1963 and as a
result of that Lyndon Johnson changed
our country because all Americans
vast majority supported voting rights
for black Americans civil rights for
black Americans every so often the giant
is awakened by something that offends no
matter where you are in the political
spectrum I don't want to say this was
worth it but if there's good to come out
of this it may be stirring the giant and
that's why Donald Trump ran so fast and
lied so much about this policy because
he one thing he is gifted at is sensing
the Giants awakening he can feel it and
the Republicans could feel it and they
ran from this if there's good to come
from children being in cages in my
beloved country it's the giant awakens
and realizes our values are at stake now
forget immigration forget taxes forget
guns important issues we are a
collection of ideas in the United States
of America and they are values and if we
lose those we're done the giant awakens
and focuses on those values our country
changes we see though here in Europe a
creeping authoritarianism in Poland now
in Hungary the response to migration
initially the idea of a census for the
Roma I'm wondering whether you sense
that America is in its own grip of the
rise of a new fascism no America is
reacting as it has done so many times
throughout its history one of the
reasons I'm an optimist is I know
American history we have been here
before our country was in the grip of
Joseph McCarthy from 1950 to 1954 we're
in the grip of the Ku Klux Klan from
1922 1924 all as a result of a reaction
to tremendous change in progress we just
had a period not only the financial
downturn we are on a path to becoming a
majority minority country I think that's
a really cool thing that's deeply
unsettling we elected a black black
president we have globalization
depriving people of their blue-collar
jobs in middle America that's deeply
unsettling and as a result we have a
reaction to that donald trump's not a
cause he's a reflection he's a product
of this unsettling inevitably the fever
breaks in america and the central values
reassert themselves
has happened so many times before it
will happen again
our job as Americans is to drive the
conversation to shorten the period of
recovery and to waken the giant as fast
as we can to speed that recovery okay
we're going to open the floor to
questions if we can have some lights up
then I can see you a bit more oh that's
much better
[Music]
finished yet we haven't finished yet
it's your turn and as I said at the
beginning if you can keep them as tight
and concise as you can we get lots more
in rights let's do them in order thank
you hi Rebecca Windsor here I thank you
for talking it was absolutely amazing
short question Donald Trump's approval
rating is surprisingly rising recently
she's trying to bring this child
Caitlyn cages policy on Democrats and
fox news's his constant cheerleader do
you think there's a chance of him being
reelected okay so will Donald Trump be
reelected don't answer that one yet
we've got this lady here number five
Mike number five thank you CNBC my
question really is them so did Trump has
repeatedly broken and long-established
protocols and for example Trump tweeting
recently about the forthcoming jobs
report that prompted a shift in
financial markets as traders speculated
strong employment figures it was a move
that essentially violated procedures
aimed at avoiding market-moving
disclosures oh that so sorry so my
question is what do you see for the
futures will these so-called longest
stablished protocols be once again
restored after the Trump administration
okay or have Trump's actions set
precedents for a tenuous White House
relationship right so for example
tweeting job figures breaking the the
market rules by treating job figures are
we going to go back or has he broken
those protocols for good that's number
two and sir yes thank you how likely do
you think it is for the giant to weaken
up in time for the midterm elections
there we go you can choose your order so
do you think Trump will get reelected
because his approval rating seemed
actually to be holding in some cases
growing do you think the protocols who's
broken will remain broken and will the
giant awakened in time for November for
the midterms yeah
great questions and and they connect
obviously in a lot of ways I'll take the
reelection first it's possible in this
way he has the reliable support at least
so far of in the upper-30s percent of
the people in opinion polls
which seems depressing until you
realized that Richard Nixon on the day
he resigned had a 36 or 37 percent
approval rating there's always gonna be
a portion of America that for reasons
that we've touched on here today
believes that there's a the trade of the
impact on our values for the policy
gains is worth it it's just always gonna
be that way
the vast majority his numbers have
creeped up towards forty percent still
historically low the vast majority
disagree if they turn out and vote which
is one of the things I'm trying to
accomplish
I'm never gonna run for office but I
need people to vote their values so that
the giant awakens and participates in
the election but he's counting on this
that the Democrats will pick someone
from the far left it talked about the
wings and the nuts at the wings that
they'll pick someone far left and that
will lead the great middle to stay home
they won't vote for that they won't vote
for him but they'll stay home or an
independent candidate will be compelled
to run in the middle and he'll get
reelected with thirty four thirty five
percent of the vote it's possible I
don't know whether it's likely it's also
possible that he sees if it shakes out
the Democrats picks someone who can
actually attract run on a values
campaign and attract the middle he may
decide he's already made America great
I'm going back to casinos or whatever it
is so that's the first will will the
giant awake and then I'll come to the
normal
inevitably yes the only thing new is the
history you don't know I have a pretty
good sense of American history and the
patterns of it the giant always awakens
now sometimes it takes a while Winston
Churchill said you can always count on
Americans do the right thing after they
have exhausted all other possibilities
they do you think in terms of the the
midterms do you think Donald Trump can
hold always John senator hold on to the
house I don't I don't know whether
awakened in time for the midterms these
children in cages is a big big deal for
all the right reasons being horrifying
and touching our core values as
Americans and so we'll see there's an
energy in America that's inspiring right
now we have record numbers of women
running for political office
[Applause]
we have kids engaging in ways they
haven't in a generation or more on
issues across not just guns but on lots
of issues we have people and I don't
mean this sarcastically there's a
renewed appreciation by Republicans for
Barack Obama and by Democrats for george
w bush because those are very different
people but they were both
traditionalists and institutionalists
who respected the office and so people
are starting to rise above the reason I
called this book a higher loyalty is to
me all of leadership in life is about
looking first at the things at the
higher level the values so I see that
happening and being hastened by what's
happening to these kids and I think we
may see us maybe a slightly groggy giant
but a much more awakened giant come
November than even today now in terms of
the norms President Trump has broken all
kinds of norms the norms about the
control of jobs figures and those sorts
of things are very important to my mind
not as important as the norm that we
judge our presidents by their tether to
the truth we will get back to our norms
but our recovery period will be longer
or shorter based on how we act today we
cannot become numb to the destruction of
the norms and I'll make it very personal
president of the United States of
America wakes up nearly every week some
morning and tweets that I should be in
jail okay I laugh I actually does not
bother me at all because I know it's
silly there's nothing there I'm not
worried at all and then I stop myself
and say shame on you you are becoming
numb to the President of the United
States of America pronouncing the
incarceration of a private citizen and
so I refuse to be numb one of the
reasons I'm doing this is I refuse to be
numb and I'm going to talk about this
until it's no longer necessary to talk
about if we don't become numb he will
still break norms but the next president
United States I don't care who it is who
he or she is what party they're from
they will take office talking about
values and norms and tradition and
respect and Prejudice and all the values
that have been
offended by this president they will
have to and we will make it easier for
them maybe put some pressure on them by
not forgetting what's going on here
today that's going to be
three more questions if we can from the
circle this time
number seven yeah there is
you may raise the issue of potentially
being jailed by Republican president
you've got a Republican Congress there's
a whole lot of pressures in the system
which might lead to another Republican
Congress after this one and possibly the
reelection of Trump have you thought
that the best option for you would be to
go down the road to the Ecuadorian
Embassy in the sauna because you both
seem to be very very good at leaking
American secrets right okay so in the
style of Julian Assange a sweet yeah are
you a leaker of American secrets sir
I'll take your question next and then
I'll come to this side is there a lady
there yet number six there sir
recent reports have shown that while
you're conducting in the investigation
into Hillary Clinton's emails that you
were using your own private gmail
account don't you think that that's a
bit hypocritical and that cast a shadow
over the FBI yep okay the gmail account
yeah I'd like to ask about tampering
with voting machines and whether you're
aware of any credible reports that
voting machines were tampered with in
such a way that would affect the tally
yeah voting machines okay let's take one
more so there's a lady behind you yep
I'm wondering that what the chances do
you think of the giant going back to
sleep if Trump is not really like it the
joint going back to slugger if it's fine
okay you're ahead of me on that one
though right so just in summary them
Julian Assange Gmail's voter machines
and the giant yep I don't need the Asajj
suite at the Ecuadorian Embassy for two
reasons first that would be exactly what
I don't want to do which is withdrawing
from the conversation in the United
States and I defy anyone to show where I
have disclosed classified information in
anything that I've said or written or
done second point that's the Gmail
answer right
Asante okay
[Music]
second the the gmail thing yeah it's
absolutely true that I wrote my own
speeches as director of the FBI that I
would write them at home on my personal
laptop and then send them to my office
account these public speeches on my
gmail account to my government account
and if I want to keep working on the
draft I would then send it back home
then send it back into my office it
reflects a fundamental misunderstanding
and I'm sorry to say even by Hillary
Clinton herself about what the
investigation was about you said this at
the beginning it was not about her use
of a non governmental email system I
don't care it was about did she
mishandled classified information
by talking about it on an unclassified
system there is not any accusation that
any of my speeches involve classified
information so I I guess I get why it
was included in the report but it
reflects a confusion about what the
investigation was what was the next one
facing machines voting machines the good
news is no just to explain that yes she
never found any evidence that the vote
itself was hacked that Russian hackers
or anybody else reached down to the
precinct level to the machines the great
thing about the American electoral
system is it's a huge hairball that
there's no centralization whatsoever
it's an old lady and an old man wheeling
something out under the basketball hoop
at a gym
it's very very difficult to penetrate we
never found any evidence of penetration
we found evidence that the Russians had
penetrated voter registration databases
at the state level but and we're not
actually sure what they were doing with
that but that they never went attempted
or got to a voting machine and the
fourth one and the fourth one was oh the
giant if it goes back to sleep so could
there be more Trump and more
unconsciousness there will be I mean the
pattern of American history is there
will be it will happen again it's
happened many times in our history
Abraham Lincoln was followed by a man
named Andrew Johnson as president to the
United States he was a raving race
and a demagogue who immediately reversed
reconstruction in a civil war south he
was a terrible person he was followed by
ulysses s grant who despite corruption
issues did extraordinarily good things
for newly freed black americans and
reinstated Reconstruction America a lot
of Americans here you all know this it's
this amazing bumpy diverse occasionally
screwed-up mostly wonderful collection
of people that shouldn't exist right
we're not unified by race nationality
ethnicity religion any of the normal
things that cause a nation to form we
formed around a set of values that's a
recipe for some wonderful things and for
tremendous volatility in our country and
we've seen it since we started is a book
I would recommend to you not my own book
called the soul of America by Jon
Meacham that I just finished where he
traces these patterns of American
history
I left that book consoled that we have
been screwed up so many times before
that we will not only recover from this
we will be screwed up again I think that
might be the first the only book tour
where you actually recommend somebody
else's book as a spirit too of that I'm
gonna go right up to the top to the I
think we call that the balcony number
eight yes hello can I ask if you could
go back to September October 2016
knowing what you know now
so knowing about the Trump Tower meeting
knowing about all of the interactions
between Trump associates and trend
campaign officials and Russia and
knowing that there was a real
possibility that Trump would be elected
president what would you do anything
differently okay what and why what do
you would you do anything differently if
you could live that again and number
nine hi my name is Nina mohanty I'm an
American citizen
as well living here I wanted to thank
you so much for your service
I once had a dream of working for the
FBI and I no longer do so what advice
would you give to young Americans like
myself who feel a strong calling to
serve but feel a bit disillusioned or
put off public service right now given
the political climate great ok thank you
very much
is there anyone up there is there one
more up there I'll take one more
hi my name is Chloe Thomas I'm at the
student at the University of Virginia I
was wondering if you think that there'll
be Russian interference in the upcoming
midterms if you think so I didn't hear
that
Russia interference okay let's I'm gonna
put Russia in big bold capitals now and
ask you to expand on Russia interference
how far do you think it goes do you
think it's in the midterms do you think
it was part of anything that happened
here with the brexit vote do you think
it has changed the way elections have
gone since 2016 or before if you don't
mind me piggybacking onto the rest of
that and the other two questions this
lady says she'd like to work for the FBI
but feels very disillusion now about
gained public service in America and
what would you change if you could go
back to September October 2016 yeah what
would I change question I've asked
myself that probably not a million times
but probably a thousand times and I've
asked myself this question if I knew
what I know now would I do something
deeply unprincipled in October and
concealed and that's a hard question I
I'd like to think I would still do what
I did I would still even knowing the
future no I can't do that as director of
the FBI I can make decisions based on my
assessment of politicians and one of the
searing moments on October 27th was one
of the best lawyers I had was a woman
who was very quiet and brilliant and I
used to have to draw her into
conversations because if you could get
words to come out of her mouth
you needed to listen to them and she
actually volunteered and said should you
consider that what you're about to do
may help elect Donald Trump President of
the United States and ice
thank you for asking that question
because I suspect it was on a lot of
minds
I said not for a moment because down
that path lies the death of the FBI as
an independent force in America if I
ever start making calls that way we're
just another partisan tribe so I don't
think I would do anything different but
it would be an even harder decision if I
was back there now able to see the
future can I talk about the FBI recruit
for the FBI hmm
one of the reasons fact the main reason
I wrote a book is not to write about
Donald Trump or Hillary Clinton's emails
but to write about ethical leadership so
that I could offer a vision especially
to young people of what it can be and
what it should be so they don't withdraw
we need you so much we need you so much
and we can't have you saying it's just
so icky and pulling back from public
service from public life we have to have
you and so what I hope to do is show
people there's a whole lot of good
people making really hard decisions but
in a thoughtful ethical way and it's
really cool to do moral work work with
moral content it doesn't pay any money
it's incredibly stressful it's addictive
and one of the things I hope with the
book is to show people that vision of
leadership and what it's like to choose
to do good for a living you will never
regret it but there's a chance today
young people are gonna pull back now I
said to you already see in the United
States they're resisting that they're
literally out in the street
participating but it's still a danger
Russia the last one was about Russia
lady was asking specifically about
Russia interference in the midterms if
we can just piggyback on that and
because there's a lot of debate as well
in this country about what those Russia
interference in the brexit vote or other
causes so I want to be very careful
about I don't want to answer the
question about brexit that's a question
that the UK authorities should answer
it's a very important question to ask
because of the nature of Russia's active
measures campaigns they actively and
regularly interfere in proceedings of
the West with the overwhelming goal
being to divide us and weaken us and
undermine our democracy
ah cracy they came for our election not
because of Donald Trump or because of
Hillary Clinton
they came overwhelmingly because they
don't want America or the UK to be a
shining city on the hill to inspire
other democracies they want to show the
world it's just as corrupt and dirty as
anything else don't listen to them now
in our case Putin also happened to hate
Hillary Clinton and decided he likes
businesspeople he can make deals with
them
he liked Donald Trump they succeeded
beyond their wildest dreams their
wildest dreams
not only did Donald Trump get elected
president who refuses to criticize even
in private
Vladimir Putin but look at the division
that we see in our country right now so
you bet you they're coming back for 2018
they will sure be back in the United
States in 2020 and I'm very worried I've
been out of the government for over a
year so I don't know for sure but I see
indications that we are not doing much
to try to meet that threat the outgoing
director of the NSA and someone I very
much liked Admiral Mike Rogers testified
publicly that he has tools that could be
used to thwart that threat that are not
being deployed because he has not been
given the authority Mike Rogers is a guy
who does not say much that's deeply
concerning so they will be back and we
will not be adequately prepared for it
why not why do you think there's no one
on the well on either side on
Republicans or Democrats side that are
willing to implement what you need to do
to stand up that well I think the only
thing you can point out is the executive
branch led by Donald Trump because
Democrats don't have the power and
there's a reluctance that I honestly
can't fully explain by the president
personally to take action adverse to
Russia there's energy in the Congress to
do that even energy I gather from media
accounts and lower levels in the White
House not in the President himself I
don't know whether that's there's a
causal connection between that and what
Admiral Rogers were saying but it seems
reasonable to me we've got about five
more minutes let's take some yeah we're
back down here make them really good
ones number five
Michael Flynn but not that's bolt for
the door what do you think of this whole
breaks it malarkey what do you think
this breaks it malarkey what do you
think of doing yeah right what do you
think of brexit that's kind of open um
part from the malarkey bit um yes I les
Liberto former Clinton Foundation
employee curious um how do you think the
media plays into sort of the current
situation and what extended and played
out with your investigation
and if the media is doing it wrong if
perhaps they contributed to the election
of Donald Trump the role of media in in
swerving in in in the election itself
and covering the and McLaren yep
absolutely
and three hi Ben Miller you said 28th of
October 2016 was such a tough decision
nine days later you went to Congress and
said actually no problem despite several
hundred thousand emails you went through
during that period of time you must
become increasingly confident there
wasn't an issue had you waited 24 hours
of 48 hours you don't know more had you
waited four days you'd have known more
surely there was no reason to decide on
the 28th to speak you could have waited
a few days you could have gained some
confidence where there was something
really there before you put your nose
into election okay
did everyone get that so why would you
open an investigation on the 28th that
you thought was gonna take you forever
actually that stayed you had hundreds of
thousands of new emails on their Weiner
laptop and yet actually it was all over
and done with in nine days so right why
didn't you wait why didn't you wait a
few days to see what your head writes a
good question um start with brexit
malarkey I'm feeling this one's gonna be
short not to disappoint Michael Flynn
wants to know about brexit I I don't
think I am I'm in a position to comment
as an American it doesn't make much
sense to me as someone who just flew
from London City Airport to Berlin and
then from Hamburg back here I can only
imagine what a pain in the rear it's
gonna be down the road and how bad that
will be for commerce in the UK I don't
know why you would do that honestly do
you think it's gonna happen if you'll
sense what it won't happen
no disease bug there's a book wisdom of
the crowd sometimes the crowd is not
wise right do I think it's gonna happen
do I think it's gonna happen I don't
know that I'm not I'm not informed
enough to tell you whether it's gonna
happen or not so that's the malarkey
answer role of the media in a selection
and now in supporting and criticizing
Trump
that's a such a great question that
calls for a long and probably more
sophisticated answer that I can give but
let me just pick a couple of pull a
couple of threads one is the current
structure of the media and the nature of
human brains creates a craving for the
next conflict conflict narrative
conflict narrative conflict narrative
car accidents we can't look away from
even though we tell ourselves we won't
you wait in line because of a traffic
jams of car accident you will look at
the car accident when you get up there
because you've earned it and that's the
way people think and so I don't know
what to do about that that the attention
is so short and the craving for conflict
is so extraordinary and this is one of
Donald Trump's several reflections of
his genius he sees that he knows that he
can tell a lie that's a there's a crime
wave in Germany that's false and then
you're told the facts and then he
repeats it the next day so whatever this
was this is a lie because you know it's
not true now that was I think yesterday
or the day before it's gone in America
because we're on to the next thing the
next thing and I don't have a great
answer for that first second the the
media is now obviously much larger than
journalism the way in which we receive
information share information process
information leaves us very susceptible
to tribalism and manipulation in America
we frankly didn't need the Russians to
so division we do that so incredibly
well through Facebook and Twitter on our
own
I'm on Twitter I don't read Twitter
comments there's some ugliness out there
it's a reflection and it also produces
this division among us and we live this
room is full of these brains that have
this incredible confirmation bias
I crave information consists of what I
already believe and I will not
consciously process information that's
inconsistent and then I'm able to
program my life to receive only
information consistent with it I don't
know what to do about that
so I just wanted to depress you with a
couple of small things the way we get
information the way we communicate with
each other has changed in ways all of
you understand as well or better than I
do and that changes the way not just
that we live but the way we are led and
the way we evaluate our leaders and I'm
not expert enough to tell you what to do
about that seems really unfair to make
you end on this rather sticky one about
the dates no this is a great but with
that the question is its October 28th
and the team tells me we got hundreds of
thousands of emails we cannot I press
them so hard on this they said we cannot
complete the review before the election
it'll take weeks and weeks and weeks for
two reasons we don't have the capability
to deduplicate electronically on our
classified networks all this material
has to be on our classified networks
because we know it contains classified
information and so we'll have to read
each email and we can't bring in
recruits like we would to look for a
knife or a gun at a crime scene
because they have to know context
there's only six or eight or ten people
who can actually do this and know what
they're looking for so we have to have a
small group of people read hundreds of
thousands of emails we cannot possibly
finish it and I pressed impressed
impressed and so given that why would I
wait now to come back to the question
knowing what you know now I forgot this
if I knew now that the Wizards at the
FBI's operational technology division
would write custom software that could
be loaded onto the classified network
and deed
electronically and cut it down to six
thousand unique emails that had to be
read that they could then read night
after night after night after night and
finish on the Sunday before the election
you're damn right I might have waited I
might have the reason I say might is two
things if you wait and then find out
it's significant you're even closer to
the election and also Loretta Lynch
raises to me there's the prospect of a
leak we're seeking a criminal search
warrant in New York so the circle of
people who know about this has just
gotten a whole lot larger what if it
leaks the week before the election then
you've got the worst of both you've
spoken through a leak and you concealed
it and we're exposed by a leak and so
look a reasonable person might have said
let's wait four days and see what
happens
give them what they were telling me I
couldn't think of a logical reason to
wait and and then once they finished
again the Press reports this all the
time they found nothing no no no not
true we found thousands of new emails we
found new we found emails with
classified information in them we found
things that made us need to investigate
further but not as to Hillary Clinton it
did not change the investigators view of
Hillary Clinton even though we found new
material and so look if I'd known we
could have gotten it done I might have
taken the chance of waiting although
even that would be dangerous the only
dispute actually that only the diversity
of opinion in the bureau team of twelve
that argued about this was having
finished should we tell Congress that it
hasn't changed our view and there were
one or two dissenters who I think we're
just so pained by the whole experience
they said we shouldn't be talking
anymore and my view was look I told
Congress we reopen this thing if you are
all really done and you're telling me
it's not fatigue talking but you are
done and our view has not changed how do
I conceal that from the American people
and so I sent the second letter on a
Sunday and then I went and got a
margarita as big as my head
[Laughter]
you've called your book a higher loyalty
you've said that you have no interests
no desire to go into politics I'm
assuming that as an FBI director you
didn't vote would I be wrong correct I
did not so now you're a private citizen
who do you want to vote for in 2020
you're not a Republican anymore do you
vote Democrat who is your ideal
candidate I don't I know it's not I
intend to find and God willing there
will be this person some man or woman
who most importantly reflects those
values and I don't care that much about
their policy views the next president
has to restore has to move the line back
up when it comes to truth and the rule
of law and equal protection of the law
the things are at the heart of the
United States
I hope the Democrats are thoughtful
enough to find somebody who reflects
those values and can attract a big
portion of the giant if that happens
this will not be a close call and that's
the person I want to vote for I don't
know who that person is yet so I'm not
prepared to answer your follow-up
question but I I crave America craves
that person who can represent us and say
this is who we are as a country and so
that's who I'll vote for Jim Comey what
an absolute pleasure to talk to you this
evening thank you
you
[Applause]